the elections heating up and Joe
Swensons learning if the Lib Dems are to
stop brexit they'll need some help with
a deal now struck three parties across
60 seats have mutually agreed not to
stand against each other the scale of
the arrangement unprecedented as Liberal
Democrats we are determined to stop
breaks it we want to remain in the
European Union so that we can have a
brighter future and we're proud to work
with other parties who share our goal of
remaining in the EU to try to maximize
the chance of their having as many
remain MPs as possible the tactical
remain pact has taken months of planning
each seat selected carefully chosen to
maximize the remain vote to me
what's failed is the fact that we have a
system based on government and
opposition but the opposition has not
felt able to oppose brexit and that
means the people in the country who
wants us to stay in the European Union
which is actually more than half the
country have felt utterly abandoned and
bereft the unite to remain alliance
already holds nine of the seats on their
list but in the others they'll be
challenging the Conservatives or labour
so could this really tip the balance of
power
let's take Cheltenham the 2017 results
suggests Green votes might help deliver
a Lib Dem victory because they need a
swing of 2.3 percent to move from second
to first
however the Lib Dems lose nothing by
giving plied a free run at clearly
considering they lost their deposit in
2017 like they did in 36 of 40 Welsh
seats they're also targeting
high-profile names like the Foreign
Secretary Dominic Raab although the
swing required is huge and all three
parties are stepping aside for prominent
remains like change UK's and a sue Bri
who left the Conservative Party and is
now defending a small majority it's not
a new idea there have been unofficial
PACs in 2017 when the Greens gave the
Lib Dems a free run in several seats
including here Richmond Park in South
Londyn I think they want to put their
differences aside for the greater good I
think it makes sense actually I'm like
pleased to hear it for once
you know people putting their you know
the good of the country first rather
than their own careers the Green Party
is it's an issue that's really important
that no but we've got to sort out breaks
it I think there's a certain a lot of
people who have a far more green agenda
than the Lib Dems normally have so I
think it will take that away from the
Richmond voters the remain alliance has
worked before bringing the Lib Dems
victory at the Brecon by-election in the
summer it's not without risk
but with brexit at stake it's a
political gamble parties are prepared to
take nor Abunda Sky News Somerset